how to slow down time
step one this doesn't actually slow down
time
it just seems slower because you're
doing something difficult so you're more
aware of it
what you got whoosh
welcome everyone today we're reviewing r
slash whoosh
for people that are just dumb perfect
for you okay let's
let's get into this what happens when i
tell people i'm colorblind
that's cool points at the object what
color is this
you forgot to put yellow into the list
i'm okay
[Music]
i feel like as a youtuber this
especially applies
because god damn don't have to read out
all the dumb comments
and a lot of times i can't tell if
people are double wishing is there a
subreddit for that the double whoosh
you can't wash your wool shirt i am not
getting mushed in this episode
didn't realize how tired i was i went to
bed at 8 pm and woke up at 1 pm
jesus ah yes minus 7 hours of sleep
no 17 hours oh thank you so much
thank you thank you so much for that oh
oh god i
now i feel stupid
so annoying the cameraman be like
it's called a drone oh what
thank you i can only imagine how slow
netflix streaming must have been
while quarantining for that 1918
pandemic there was no netflix back then
genius
yeah conan you dumb stinky but you don't
know how to make a handshake
actually he does there's photos of it oh
okay
our twitter password is the last seven
digits of pie
no hackers so far pious non-terminating
irrational number there's no last digit
[Music]
you're fun aren't you everyone loves you
you're fun to be around
that's gotta be great to be you boy
i wish i was so smart like you are wow
flintstones goodbye world flintstone
gummies
that won't kill you
you know what they say everyone's like
oh china's so bad
they're restricting their social media
and all the government is controlling
now we need it
we need less people commenting because
god damn it i'm for it
i'm saying it now internet the internet
was a mistake i've said it before i'll
say it again
god damn it
me all night trying to remember the name
of the donkey in shrek
isn't it just donkey oh wow
aren't you special thank you
thank you so much
oh geez oh why was i without youtube
comments
i have a friend who lives just outside
of general building in ukraine
he watched that drama and said he
counted nine historical inaccuracies on
one hand
it's a movie not a documentary oh okay
you want to read that again
you want to try reading that one again
if you didn't get that i'm sorry you got
whooshed he thinks
nobody can see him can see who the cat
dumbass you're so dumb
god can't you see it's a cat what are
you blind
i've never been washed in my life being
that person
not me don't know what that feels like
you suck
just spot 50 cartons of two percent milk
and mix it to get 100 milk my bones are
now
indestructible it's still two percent
myth
[Applause]
first ever picture taken of a black hole
in a visible
light spectrum no it's a can
yeah you guys don't see i bet you guys
since you guys thought this was a black
hole
invisible in the lights first picture
i've taken about light spectrum
a cat cringe i actually don't get this
joke oh god am i getting whoosh
it probably took a good year or two no
no no no i can't get worse
to make this table good year
that's the name of a tire brand
you can't boost that wusha i was you'd
get woosed
know the difference when you hit your
toe in a coral reef
are you serious uh are you
serious right now sharks don't even have
toes
question mark do they shark have's toes
does shark have toes oh god
they have fingers what what the [ __ ]
shark has toes
wait they have jeans for digits but
turn them off yeah just turn off your
digits bro
you have toes or you turn off your
digits dumbass
freaking [ __ ] are those toes are those
toes
that's why i don't have legs i just turn
off my digits bro
sheesh the manager at our local ikea is
retiring so i sent him this cake
where's the cake all right you know what
this is a whoosh this is a double whoosh
if you cringe at this that means you got
whoosh and i don't get worse
[ __ ] you i know all the ikea jokes don't
worry about it
i bet you shower naked you [ __ ]
what the frick of course i shower naked
okay [ __ ]
calm down sheesh i sent that to my
friend
all right good test to see if your
friend is a [ __ ] is your milkshake
really worth it
the second photo is a woodturning lamp
wtf
yeah answer the question is your
milkshake really worth it huh
answer the question god some people the
imposter
me hiding in a man if you're hiding in a
vent
you are an impostor
have y'all ever seen a pancake on a
rabbit lmao
this is not true about my wooden post
days
you don't know obama like i do
no you don't on one day bailey alex was
walking outside and she saw a boy crying
she said to him here here kid have a
roll of air
conditioning pear coil one quarter
three eighths 410 a 20 meter
polyethylene
uv protected insulated copper heat
resistant 2018
celsius you're destined to do great
things
that boy was elon musk
isn't wait a minute something
something seems odd about this story
isn't elon
way older than her hmm
like 30 or something
i cannot doubt this story no offense to
anyone
timeline and probability just don't add
up to me
the probability really sold me on that
one the four horsemen of any guy's most
used folders
games homework homework memes why do you
have two homework files
me trying to remember which homework
file was the right one
in front of class on the on the
projector screen
actually nike's just do it great all
right that's what you noticed
great congratulations you did it you
your brain is so
big that you notice everything oh god
amazing
well done what if they're trolling this
makes it so complicated i i don't i
don't want to get double whoosh
but there's so many people like this
that's too many of them
send them off to an island all right
vote pewdiepie i'll fix this i'll get
rid of them don't ask how
it will be nice they can all just get
together and correct each other and
everything
it's it'll be great when you're a
youtuber
everything you do is wrong there's
always that one person
oh you think that's how you do that you
think that's how you sit on a chair
no felix what you want to do is you want
to sit like this
this is how chairs what oh the
microphone that's not how microphone
[Music]
sorry i apologize you hear the one about
the airplane
no it'd probably go over your head
i'm pretty smart try me
i'm pretty smart i it's this feels i
this feels like i would double wish it
would not go over my head my reflexes
are too fast
i'd catch it [ __ ] pokemon
graphic design is my passion did i get
the job pokey
yeah you can't even make her name fit
you might as well could just
quit just quit no from now on she know
pokemon
ne shi poki mane no pokeman
pokimoney come on give him a shot
graphic design is his passion come on
people on the internet are just
always shutting each other down so sad
watching people eat alone
bro he's not alone they're just wearing
camouflage oh now i see
them thank you wow
the only open-minded president we ever
had
ah yes a slave owner and a slightly less
dedicated war criminal
should we tell him should you tell him
or should i
if he ever feeling down just remember
that neither doofenshmir's parents
showed up for his birth
how was he born if his mom was indeed
bro mom was a deep bro
mom wasn't deep bro my mom wasn't the
bro
either i it's fine all right we got a
photo of italy try building in a land
next time you stupid italians
[ __ ] yeah try how you try that
i was trying to do that
try to freak off you ignorant bee no
[ __ ]
man
you can what wow mamma mia [ __ ]
wow the woosher actually won that one
congratulations
i know that's rare thanks rare well done
i'm proud of you
you did it i will not let you leave this
house looking so improper
young lady can someone explain i only
get a fraction of the joke
it's an improper fraction four thirds
it's a pun
you're an idiot the world goes on
the world goes on the world goes on
and hopefully without you in it thank
you this has been
whoosh this has been extremely painful
but please subscribe for more videos
smash like
subscribe and profit
[Music]